[Music]
welcome to the
show this looks
cool this weekend we have a pretty cool
production so I figured it might be a
good idea to capture it see what happens
behind the scenes show you guys what we
get up to kind of how the sausage is
made at least a little bit the producer
isn't here
which means that he can make decisions
about where we stay that he doesn't have
to deal with the consequences of but we
do see this is what you don't see behind
the scenes all it looks like happens is
I sit down at a table and Andrew
huberman's opposite me service here is
fantastic solution is to harden this
side of
we're moving in I live here
now
no there's a pungent smell Mark let me
show you the crib full on Suite
microwave television fridge with nothing
in
it uhhuh how do you feel take the ride
very mhm useful you look great thanks
when I'm tired of life I can just hang
myself if I was spending the night
before a big episode fretting about
where the grip truck's going to be
stored or whether the lenses are going
to work right and it's just I can't I
couldn't do it trying to talk about
cuber husbands tomorrow I can't be
distracted about lenses and batteries
and stuff all good I mean that's got to
be I mean it's a [__] closed up gate
it's already that for tomorrow best
place most of my prep can't make video
[__] yeah so typically when we we land
uh on location we check out the set we
spent the first day looking around
looking at different potential camera
layouts potential set
layouts there's only one place to go
before we record a podcast Cheesecake
Factory what I love most about working
with Chris is our ritualistic Cheesecake
Factory visit it's super important that
we have that otherwise the whole
production falls
apart you will
see this is the third time that we've
been to this one two times in a row we
were placed at this very table he's come
in and put a special request tradition
tradition but the line between tradition
and Superstition begins to get a little
bit dicey I come back to LA again and I
get put on that table we like what if
tomorrow I forget how to speak tomorrow
what if it doesn't work what if the
building burns down film him don't film
me there we go that remain stylish you
know that's the pre podcast Cheesecake
Factory done obviously the most
important part of the weekend uh we're
going to get to bed the guys have got to
be up super early I have no idea what
happened I've never been on set when
these guys have actually built the set
so maybe it's total chaos and an
absolute catastrophe and everything's on
fire I don't know but I guess we'll find
out tomorrow
[Music]
peace for shoots like these I really
like having as much time as possible to
light cuz it's five cameras a little
farther back the process of making this
interviews happen is pretty insane uh
the production quality the team so it's
the same thing every time I get to spend
my morning making myself feel good and
prepping and stuff and then I arrive and
I have no idea what they've done so it's
kind of like Christmas every single
morning is like Christmas or a
nightmare so the process before each
interview is pretty varied I have my
prep that I need to do to get ready for
the guest to make myself feel good to be
in a good mood to make sure that I've
slept and ate appropriately and then the
rest of the boys need to make sure that
everything looks
nice this looks cool this looks really
really cool
so I have a process that I go through
before each episode especially these big
ones uh I found that I would get a
little bit anxious in my body it used to
be anxious in my mind too although
that's largely
dissipated I like to go for a walk on a
morning I like to think about what I'm
going to talk about to the guest I like
to Envision things going well sitting
inside under artificial lights all day
is not always great for the
brain
so yeah I'd be like I'd be really
[__] cranking this thing is out but
we can huh is
out we came out here to do three
interviews and uh unfortunately we had
someone drop out relatively at the last
minutes just before I started recording
with Andrew hubman I realized that
onethird of the entire shoot had just
been thrown out of the window and I
needed to change that so obviously we
come here it's expensive to put all of
this together so we try and maximize the
amount of shoots that we can get per
Setter uh so yeah we're just seeing what
we can do so Chase lives in LA and works
a lot here so he'll try and yeah Bing
the
guest tough schedules are tough so yeah
uh it's not quite as smooth sailing as
it could be all the time we need to
Pivot and find someone else for tomorrow
morning put the [__] put the call out
let's see what he can
do it's a little bit tough to have the
pressure on you if you you know that
there's an awful lot riding on this
you've spent you know 20 or 30 grand for
one 3our block and if you mess up then
it's a big
waste I want you just focus on this
Andrew is going to arrive in an hour so
not ideal timing but I I don't want to
get distracted by thinking about
tomorrow while I'm trying to record with
him today so I've sent a few texts we'll
see we'll see what comes
back
okay Andrew is a world class like
absolutely worldclass podcaster so he
makes it
easy the most fun part of this podcast
is the conversations I did it six years
ago I started doing it because I wanted
to have conversations with interesting
people the only thing that's changed is
the quality of the lights and the number
of people that watch all right good yeah
feel great you're on the other side get
off my side
get off my side it's a reshaping of the
m d Let's do let's [__] I want to start
talking about this get comfortable so
we hold on rolling a rolling B there you
can't teach them they've tried
to I did it uh get I did it 3 2 one Dr
Andrew hman wel up the show a few years
ago I made the decision to turn pro with
the podcast and that meant committing
properly to putting everything that I
could into trying to be as good of a
podcaster as possible but we had more
headro to improve the quality of the
production and really make something
beautiful I'm fortunate that I have
access to some of the biggest podcast
guests on the planet now and I wanted to
make something that really felt special
I wanted something that is an occasion
that is an event that visually looked as
good as the concepts that were being
communicated and I didn't think that
anyone was doing that on the internet I
didn't think that these great guests
with fantastic ideas were being given
the Cinematic beauty that they deserved
and this is a weekend of doing that
again yeah love your podcast man your
podcast is so good it's so good I feel
proud of the stuff that we've created I
think these Cinema episodes are the most
beautiful podcast interviews that have
ever been made I I got to uh got to
repost when do
ads got do ads not done yet that's very
important got to pay the
bills that's [__] money these shoots
are very expensive and the only way that
we can afford to come and film in this
kind of quality is if we put advertisers
on I need to Now record a bunch of ads
for partners that I absolutely love
working with we'll get back to talking
to Andrew in one minute but first I need
to tell
you I I can't reach It's the final thing
that you do at the end of the shoot day
when you're the most tired when you've
been talking for the longest sometimes
this goes really well sometimes this
goes really badly after some research I
found that after a ton of research after
a ton of research I found out that Marik
health is the best thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
right here go
on press
it did it
baby this is the best part of the day
episode's done episode went well ad
reads are done all of the pain is out of
the way can't go to Cheesecake Factory
again I'm afraid but um get to chill out
tonight need to find a guest for
tomorrow morning because Robert Green's
canceled need to prepare for whoever
that is need to prepare for the guy
that's after
him actually the day is not over at all
is it Dean's currently offloading all of
the files which is one problem that we
have with these shoots storage is a big
deal like these files a massive
three-hour episode on five cameras in
four 4K is huge all the plans change the
plans that we've had for weeks have
changed in 20 hours before we're about
to shoot so trying to fix the problems
and we will uh we'll see if I manage to
do it but yeah that's day one done see
you
[Music]
tomorrow 3 2
1 I've done four episodes in probably 30
hours but four in 27 is a new record
that I don't intend on trying to beat
like this isn't a flex for me to try and
get this many episodes done in such a
short space of time but as I said it's
really expensive to get all of these
people here to get all of this kit to
get the insurance to get the venue
rental to fly everybody in it's not
cheap so try and maximize it I'm going
to keep riding this thing till the
[__] Wheels fall off like I love what
I do I love these conversations and
creating something that I think visually
respects the quality of the conversation
is pretty important all right are we uh
we we actually have a bit too much space
on this side again I need to tell you
about mud water mudat is a coffee alter
so that's the bit that you don't see how
many takes it takes to say 60 seconds of
AD reads most of which I know off by
heart all of which are products that I
use every day but by this time of the
day none of which I can remember you
think anyone would notice so if I just
did it like this no let's let's switch
out a few
the alternative oh that's nice came up
with that SL modern
wisdom first I need to tell you about
the product I've used every single day
for over SL wisdom that's drink a1.com
[Laughter]
wisdom what a rap what a [__] rap
that that's it done [__]
it so that's it that is what four
episodes in 27 hours looks like might
look way more chaotic than you thought
maybe it's completely controlled I don't
know uh but this is kind of what it
feels like to do these shoots things
change sometimes catastrophes occur
thank you for coming along seeing what
we get to I don't know yeah we see you
in the next
one wow that's heavy